hello and hoops oops welcome to this
video I coeliac all I see allowing the
bank oh yeah again yeah hey affect us
against him and it worked pretty fine so
and it's no much you need to change my
approach I can just play the normal
moves yeah I mentioned in the commentary
that I think it's kind of interesting
for white to delay yeah night a three or
this one night a three is a bit more
dynamic as you can still develop the
Bishop Knight b6 night a 5s always the
question does that work I don't know I
feel I have night before and then taking
that should should be okay in general I
think this is a fairly inoffensive line
where black you should be okay yeah I'm
getting again I'm getting stuff traded
now which is helpful for black okay
let's go here yeah probably just taking
and droopy eight or maybe queen d 7b
five that's also kind of interesting
yeah let's do that looking at the square
on d3 yeah Queen to be five is a move
now it's that bad it cannot be really
bad to be honest 96 Teague's hmm yet it
can cannot be bad for me really if he
goes within my
let's do it that seems ok maybe it's
still 96 and then taking on before bit
ok this one yeah I thought that this
should be very ok the B file maybe
bishop is three-year to get to a seven
hmm ok the attitudes that looks equally
sure um ok yeah i wonder i can go quincy
seven and keep this on the board we'll
just go here I think it's better to go
to before just trade a against be porn
which is a bit stale admittedly but Wow
and I know I know I thought somehow I
thought with the bishop but probably
this was a ridiculous idea anyway so
what I was thinking is isn't it a little
bit awful for him if I awkward and if i
go here and then tiguan be too with the
bishop that threatens rugae one winning
and NTM okay maybe this was the only
move then hmm kind of interesting still
so look a one Kim
it's not doing all that much okay for
something maybe that's not really
hanging but
I have some chances here I mean not a
lot really not but I have some ideas in
based on on this e4 pawn f5 is also very
important move that can be used to
undermine and center a little bit maybe
this still gives some slight ideas and
now the five sir is a potential target
of course it's possible just cover it
yeah this is an interesting move I
wasn't sure if this is good to be honest
really not rockview one is going King it
too let's see here this is a little bit
awkward for him okay my time isn't all
that great that's important check and so
yes to go back and I can go look okay i
am now try to invade Kim g5 King edge
form so it still doesn't feel entirely
trivial ok so I'm time morning yeah I
know that blunders this one not a good
idea
okay let's go here first cannot do all
that much to be honest it's really still
it's still nothing it's still pretty not
pretty much nothing but i can try is I
can try to trade this why am before and
c5 but that gives that allows the rook
to come come up rookie one I mean
18 seconds that'sthat's the problem Wow
one foot did I spend all the time on
really not sure about this I it wasn't a
particularly complicated game sometimes
you have an immediate idea that I had
this issue I really don't know where the
time went here
Wow Kim G 2 wasn't possible at all white
resigns yeah I don't know I kind of have
his number I have like no 18 out of 21
against him and he's not bad liberated
and ya kin kin G too ok um I don't know
why should lose here of course my idea
was this to get rid of the bishop and
try against those points but nothing
going on that it was just very equal ish
maybe in order to keep more fight I
should go to see settlement and it felt
like I could have something here but
rook f1 was really ok maybe I should
play a for now I wasn't sure really play
it now but probably objectively you
cannot win here anyway and it's just
it's just too solid check yeah it's it's
it's equal all the way until this move
they should play something like that and
it's very likely well I don't know maybe
I would have done okay timewise but it
would be tricky i would have would have
done this i needed to be very quick then
I don't know I sadly squandered away my
time ok guys thanks for watching